le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
le sport est un moyen de cohésion
sociale très fort particulièrement à la
réunion
c'est pourquoi le département accompagne
les sportifs de haut niveau dans leurs
démarches administratives mais aussi en
les aidant financièrement comme bien
d'autres alizée morel championne
réunionnaise de natation qui
s'illustrent nationale bénéficient de
ces aides indispensables à la poursuite
de sa discipline
[Musique]
29e meeting de natation de l'océan
indien à la piscine du chaudron
de nombreuses figures locales qui
s'illustre désormais en métropole en
europe et même à l'international sont
présentes parmi ses têtes d'affiché
alizée morel retour aux sources pour la
championne de 22 ans à la réunion pour
quelques jours elle nous ouvre sa porte
bonjour bienvenue chez moi syvie mois
nage depuis 12 13 ans on va pas j'en ai
vu mourir d'anciens nageurs de niveau
grâce à qui j'ai commencé la compétition
mon père est un ancien nageur données
vous a mis dans les bassins assez
rapidement on voit là c'est une passion
médailles donc celle que j'ai gagnées
aux jeux des îles menacées telles des
seychelles et ses lacets de la réunion
plus récemment assisté de mon papa elle
date un petit peu plus celle qu'il a
gagné projet des villes et pour les
autres compétitions
tu vois ça c'est sûr mais le premier
déjeuner ils sont 19 et 5 médailles
devant je suis contente d'avoir donné un
peu le la dès de la compétition n'ont
pas pu enfin maternelle et et aux
maîtres nageurs ont pas des nageurs de
niveau d'emploi on a tout simplement
baigné là dedans ça qui m
sa médaille d'or aux jeux d'exil au
premier chef
et moi j'en ai réponse ça va j'ai battu
faire encore c'était mon objectif
la natation une affaire de famille chez
alizée morel la compétition samedi au
fur et à mesure va là j'ai pris goût
j'ai fait aux entraînements je prenais
du plaisir un entraînement donc
forcément je feins je progressais très
vite et finale en compétition je me
débrouillais pas mal donc ça va donner
la jeune fille se montre rapidement
performante et compétitrices la machine
est lancée
alizée s'illustre sur de nombreuses
compétitions et passent pros encore
faut-il en avoir les moyens
évidemment 20 le sport à haut niveau
coûte très cher surtout qu'on est un
sport où il ya pas beaucoup de moyens
voilà on n'est pas comme le football par
exemple on doit acheter la combinaison
qui coûte 500 euros par exemple pour une
fille ondes en acheter au moins 4,5 par
an et à lire aussi dans tous les
déplacements voilà quand ce jeu quand tu
m'a traîné à la réunion il fallait les
enfants ces championnats de france et
c'était un coup vraiment énorme j'ai
aussi également droit
à des primes aux résultats en
championnat de france 1re 2e 3e
on a une petite prime avec avec le
département j'ai pu bénéficier donc
d'une bourse à hauteur de 950 euros par
trimestre c'est une vraie aide au final
pour pour tout ce qui est logistique
dans les compétitions pour tous qui
aussi est de loyer tout ce qui vit
quotidienne aussi tout ce qu'ils achats
de lunettes 20 jours de natation a pris
on a la chance aussi d'avoir un billet
par an mais qui nous permet donc de
revenir pour se ressourcer tout ça grâce
au département pour permettre à alizée
de financer une partie de son équipement
de ses études et de son quotidien
le département propose donc différentes
aides nous avions voulu à la fin des
années 80 mettre en place une politique
pour le sport de haut niveau à travers
d'abord parce qu'on appelle les pôles
espoirs donc avec l'état nous avons
réfléchi à la façon de créer ces pôles
espoirs et 1,8 à la réunion aujourd'hui
est nous qui finançons toujours avec
l'état
cette pole survie très concrètement nous
avons mis en place trois types d' aide
pour les sportifs de haut niveau d'abord
l'aide à la continuité territoriale ça
ne s'appelait pas comme ça à l'époque
permettent un sportif de haut niveau
d'aidé en métropole de revenir au moins
deux fois par an l'aide à la performance
dès lors qu'un sportif de haut niveau
réussissez obtenir un titre champion de
france champion d'europe
résumons a fortiori effectivement devant
des possibilités de primes qui peuvent
varier entre 200 et 2000 euros en
fonction du titre et bien entendu des
bourses départementales qui varient
entre 650 euros et 1200 euros par
trimestre
une démarche simple et dématérialisés
dont vous pouvez faire le suivi en ligne
les aides indispensables pour alizé qui
n'a matériellement pas le temps de
travailler à côté pour s'autofinancer
alors moi je m'entraîne 35 heures par
semaine si ce n'est plus voilà avec 5
heures de muscu aussi qui est compris
dans l'entraînement et la journée finie
plus ou moins puisque je me remets au
travail après je ne travaillais un petit
peu aussi le soir on a aussi beaucoup de
vagues de compétition à raison de trois
ou quatre par par mois c'est très
chargée dans le cas du temps d'un
sportif de haut niveau
j'ai pas le temps d'avoir un petit
boulot à côté comme tout bien que cela
ne fasse pas partie des obligations du
département la collectivité a décidé de
devenir un partenaire à part entière des
sportifs locaux pour les accompagner
dans des parcours dits d'excellence
sportive
[Musique]
on est là pour aider tous ces sportifs
qui sont amenés à effectivement brasser
le niveau quel que soit deux catégories
d'âge et quelle que soit l'origine fait
en sorte que le jeune réunionnais qui a
un talent naissant puisse embrasser des
carrières nationale internationale et
mondiale
c'est très gratifiant finale parce que
parce que voilà nos efforts ne servent
pas rien le sport c'est décès de très
beaux souvenirs cette belle performance
et des émotions tout ça mais c'est
vraiment servir de cette notoriété qui
est libre qui commence à grandir moi je
parle pour tout le monde il faut faire
va donc le pas en fait elle se renseigne
et voilà moi je me suis renseigné tu
partais sur le site j'ai contacté j'ai
appelé le département j'ai envoyé des
mails en gt tour est venu
heureusement les départements mais
l'engagement du département contribue
incontestablement à développer le sport
réunionnais que ce soit sur le nombre de
licenciés sur la diversité des
disciplines mais aussi des équipements
sportifs
sans oublier la gratification de voir
nos sportifs locaux faire briller la
réunion dans le monde entier
à la réunion 64 disciplines sportives
sont représentés elle compte en tout
plus de 5 en 2008 censier chaque année
le département soutient 800 clubs
financièrement il existe trois aides
pour le sport de haut niveau
une bourse allant de 650 à 1250 euros
par trimestre une prime à la performance
variant de 160 à 2300 euros selon
l'importance de la compétition
une aide à la mobilité allant de 400
euros à quatre billets d'avion pris en
charge par an pour plus d'informations
rendez vous au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]